if you've ever ordered anything from
origin PC then you probably know they
come in these giant tough wooden crates
they're really hard to open sometimes
like we had a lot of trouble last time
when you got them so this time we're
gonna try something different we're
gonna open them with crowbars half life
style are you ready mm-hmm Wow these
have everything I ever wanted it's an
Intel i7 processor a 980ti GPU 32 gigs
of DDR 4 RAM oh my gosh and a PCI slot
400 gigabyte SSD oh my god this is
everything I ever wanted
do you only play so many video games I
mean edit so many videos gonna edit so
many game videos thanks dude all thoes
gigahertz I'm making it really heavy
yeah I'm gonna go put this in